I'm John now by the labor pier and the
international coordinator of the
Dominica relief effort we're storm Erika
has just hit that's berenice Scotland
good evening to you and we heard that
the El Ninos being held accountable for
torrential rain how has dropped called
storm Erika affected the island of
Dominica well it's absolutely devastated
dominica it's the biggest humanitarian
disaster you like in the last two years
if you look at per capita and our
population we have a small population of
70,000 every village in Dominica has
been affected we have 365 rivers that
she every River has broken its bank has
been swamped by mudslides and the rain
has been devastating we've got 31 people
have died hundreds are have been made
homeless and many are still missing so
it's the biggest disaster in Dominica
since hurricane david back in 1979 and
it's caused much more loss of life so
it's heartbreaking what can be done if
anything to protect islands and
countries like Dominica from this type
of a while really devastating weather
conditions I think we extreme weather I
think we've got to take climate change
utterly seriously some people think this
is just an optional extra for islands in
the Pacific and four islands in the
Caribbean this is our lifeblood many of
these islands are going to be not only
damage with some will even disappear
unless we take real action now we know
the UN is going to have a climate change
conference in Paris there's some really
difficult challenging issues I know that
the Pacific and the Caribbean are saying
we have to be harder edged in what we do
and we've got to do it together because
this is affecting all of us it's
Dominica today we know it's another
island tomorrow in the Caribbean but
also in the Pacific this is critically
important and right now Dominica is
suffering a terrible loss we think that
we've probably had more than 250 million
pounds worth of damage there's a
suggestion that we are putting back
infrastructure in dominica by 20 years
so this is a body blow to the people of
Dominica who are still in desperate need
of relief and who are just spinning
really in terms of the horror of what's
happening to them jordaan leakers
candidate iran a sexually General of the
Commonwealth extreme weather conditions
something that affects very many
countries within the Commonwealth do you
have policies or ideas in how to deal
with this as a cohesive body I think one
of the things we have to do is to know
how to respond better sadena which is
the Caribbean disaster response agency
have done a magnificent job but but what
I have found is not every single country
or every single region has an
organization similar to that so when
something happens you know exactly where
to go to whoo-hoo to speak to and how to
get relief and I think there's an
opportunity for us to learn from what's
happened and try and put some mechanism
together so we can better coordinate
better respond and actually get to know
that this thing is going to happen more
easily we didn't know in Dominica there
was a very late warning people looked
and thought it was just another storm
well this storm has caused devastation
and what we're really seeing is that
storms and hurricanes now are coming
closer and closer together in terms of
their impact and Dominica is just one
example of how terrible things can be
and we really have to make a better fist
at coming together working in
partnership to deliver real change have
you been able to get the UK involved in
the relief effort well the UK have
actually been amazing immediately they
gave 300,000 pounds for immediate relief
but also much more significantly we had
Lyme Bay who was redirected that the
ship which was nearly in the region off
going somewhere else but they were sent
to come and give immediate relief to
Dominica they had everything on it water
food things to make housing so many
people are homeless so I really want to
say a very warm thank you to all the
international agencies including here
and abroad
for the things they've done and our
partners in the Caribbean have just been
magnificent they immediately came to the
aid of Dominica even getting the Prime
Minister back on island because there
was no way of getting in both airports
were gone and our friends i think in
Barbados and trinidad helped us with
helicopters ought to take you back to a
previous role that is a tourney general
under a Labour government obviously
you'll know they the news I need been
outer that the country but sir where do
you think Jeremy Corbyn is taking a
Labour Party well I think you've got to
acknowledge that Jeremy Corbyn got the
vote it's the most overwhelming
endorsement and I think that we've got
to look to see what happens the people
have spoken we all believe in democracy
so this is what we're going to see many
good have any disappointment on your
part I think I'm disappointed we didn't
win the last election very diplomatic
answer thank you very much but she's
just got a nice aroma